brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest a festival
where tech music film gaming all collide
in Austin and at least three of those
four low key here is responsible for it
loki your chrome acota studios and
you're here showing off the music room
is that right it is indeed yeah now tell
me a little bit about the music room
because to walk by your booth in there
see people wailing away on the drums but
they're in a VR headset so the music
room is a collection of VR musical
instruments so you put on the headset
you transport it to this to arrange
different rooms and then you can play a
range of different instruments alright
so talk me through some of the
instruments give me to give me the
bullet point run down so the one you
probably saw a few people wailing on
we've got a drum kit yeah I'm kind of
normal drum kit but with lots of
different ways to control it you know
different things you can map two
triggers so you can change filters in
real time as you're playing change what
trauma kit you're playing between
between hits so it's just a really
expressive drum kit we can do a few
things that normal electronic drum kits
can't because we've got things like
support for brushes mallets just ways
things you can't do with a normal
electronic drum kit but we also have the
other one you probably saw which is the
laser harp people are moving up and down
in the strings from tralian controlling
filters and we have this strumming
instrument which we call a cord hub
which is just a pile of strings that you
can really easily play chords on so you
mentioned songwriting yeah like when you
when people put on the vibe and they
pick take those things in hand well
actually it's also on PlayStation VR and
oculus rift correct yeah alright so when
they when they put on their headset
they've got their set up what kind of
different music experiences are you
hoping to a cultivate here you said it's
can be used as a songwriting tool are
you hoping people are going to like do
some drum practice in there yeah we want
it for the studio practice and live use
like originally I really focused on the
studio and practice kind of home
enjoyment and performance going to use
but then I had a few people really
approached me for their like lucky we
need to use this thing live that's very
interesting yet that electronic
performance kind of thing because so far
in the gaming world at least what we've
seen they're mostly you know they try to
capture the thrill of performance and
there are some
that are sort of focused on teaching
skills but this is something that you
sort of imagine an artist using on stage
yeah it's just a lot of electronic
artists are like when they're touring
they have to tour a very stripped down
kind of version the sound because they
just you know they're playing these like
complicated parts where they're doing
lots of automation or something they
they can't really play it all on a
keyboard very cool the music room for
folks are picking up VR headsets this
year early adopters is it going to be
available for them yep so it'll if we're
planning to launch with the with the
vibe so bit scarily soon we see we're
going to see exactly how how well it
goes at South by what feedback we need
to incorporate or incorporate for that
because you know we're seeing a
ludicrous amount of musicians trying it
here so we want to make sure that it's
really really great at launch really
polished but and we're going to launch
with a those fake kind of five basic
instruments that we've got and then and
like five different spaces and different
sounds for them and then we're going to
keep adding more and more on kind of DLC
excellent as long as the tambourine DLC
is in line and the maracas that's about
my musical level these days I actually
kind of do when a tambourine hahaha
alright Loki thanks so much folks that's
the music room available for VR headsets
this year perhaps but coming soon